série la zenn bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors on va revenir sur la
situation en france
mais peut-être avant un mot pourquoi
cette journée mondiale de noël résonne
particulièrement cette année alors que
le monde traverse une pandémie
aujourd'hui un centre de santé sur deux
dans le monde n'a pas accès à une eau
suffisante pour pouvoir garantir par
exemple lavage des mains des soignants
et des malades donc dans un contexte de
pandémie mondiale le manque d'accès à
cette ressource centrale un d'un point
de vue sanitaire bat saint firmin
d'autant alors on peut imaginer que la
france et qu'on répare et pas concerné
finalement et pourtant c'est plus de 7
millions de personnes qui n'ont toujours
pas d'accès sécurisé à des équipements
ou des de l'assainissement qui sont ces
populations les plus touchées
elles sont multiples sur sur le
territoire français déjà en métropole on
trouve une corrélation assez forte entre
les problématiques de mal logement et
des problématiques d'accès à l'eau tout
simplement par exemple en banlieue
parisienne dans un certain nombre de
camps ou bidonvilles ou squats où les
gens n'ont pas accès à une eau de
qualité ou un investissement de qualité
c'est une réalité autre part dans les
autres territoires français on a des
problématiques de de concentration de
caen qui font que beaucoup de personnes
sont aujourd'hui concentrés dans des
zones insalubres où l'accès à l'eau
n'est toujours pas possible par manque
aussi de volonté politique et ce sont
les enfants notamment les plus touchés
oui tout à fait dans le monde pour
prendre encore un chiffre qui nous est
remonté cette année des nations unies on
a environ trois cent mille enfants de
moins de cinq ans qui meurent chaque
année de diarrhée due à une eau de
mauvaise qualité et ce pas uniquement
dans les pays en guerre
un plan dans des pays développés alors
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre
en place un notamment en france pour
fournir l'accès à l'eau
partout sur notre notre terre et qu à ce
qu'on sait faire techniquement oui alors
l'accès à loon n'est jamais un problème
technique
on pourrait aujourd'hui avec une volonté
politique avec des moyens suffisants
apporter de l'eau pour à peu près 95 %
de la population mondiale
les solutions techniques sont là ce
qu'il faut c'est tout simplement
accepter que l'eau soit est une denrée
prioritaire parce que c'est la base de
tout on y reviendra et est donc au-delà
des enjeux politiques mettre en place ne
serait-ce que des bornes fontaines dans
tous les millions ville de manière
urgente
ça n'engage à rien au est quelque chose
qui est très facile à mettre en place
surtout sur un territoire comme la
france où le réseau est suffisant pour
couvrir il faut juste considérer que
l'eau passe au dessus de toute autre
donnée de politique alors ça veut dire
qu'avec l'augmentation de la population
le développement les changements
climatiques l'eau notamment en france on
risque pas d'en manquer alors la france
fait partie des pays qui sont dans une
catégorie de stress hydrique assez forte
mais il faut pas mal interpréter ces
chiffres stress hydrique je ne veux pas
dire manque d'accès elle s'est tout
simplement qui via une pression entre
l'eau disponible il use nécessaire mais
des pays comme la france par exemple
savent aussi clé les leurs ressources en
eau savent
réorienter et optimiser leurs ressources
en eau donc il faut pas s'inquiéter sur
le fait que le stress hydrique soit un
risque de manque d'accès à l'eau demain
par contre dans le monde
beaucoup de pays aujourd'hui n'ont pas
la possibilité de pouvoir optimiser
leurs systèmes d'eau ou n'ont pas les
ressources nécessaires en interne et
dans ce cas là il faut de la solidarité
internationale entre les états et c'est
ce qui a été mis en place ce qui a été
demandé dans le cadre des objectifs de
développement durable il ya l'eau des
membres par les membres des
nations-unies il ya quelques années et
pour lesquels pour l'instant des
objectifs sont loin d'être atteints est
en pleine tournée mis cette question
elle est cruciale aujourd'hui aller
absolument centrale
elle est absolument centrale mais je le
vois aussi comme une opportunité parce
que en france en europe dans les pays
occidentaux les gens il ya encore deux
trois ans quand on leur parlait du
manque d'accès à l'eau du manque d'accès
art ou aux ressources nécessaires pour
pouvoir se laver les mains pour se
protéger contre des épidémies ne
comprenait pas le choléra les diarrhées
par sd des éléments des considérations
vraiment très lointaine et puis avec
avec le co lead et avec la pandémie
mondiale les gens se sont rappelés à ce
qu'était à la mise en place de gestes
barrières le fait d'avoir d'accès à
d'accès à des sources d'eau pour se
laver les mains de manière régulière et
aujourd'hui on voit un écho du message
qu'on essaye de partie 2-2 de partager
depuis des années dans la réalité qu'on
rencontre dans chacun de nos foyers et
ce message est ce qu'il est entendu par
les dirigeants internationaux
alors oui en tout cas sur le papier
sur le papier on voit une volonté dans
le cadre de la lutte contre la pandémie
et donc potentiellement contre toutes
les épidémies mondiales de pouvoir
renforcer les systèmes d'eau la réalité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui et dans le cadre
humanitaire à des financements
l'humanité reliés à l'eau et à
l'assainissement ont diminué d'environ
23% pour l'année 2020 donc de là à ce
que la réelle ambition politique et des
grands mots se transforment en actes et
notamment en financement pour des
programmes humanitaires indique t out
d'urgence il ya encore un grand grand
pas et on demande donc à la communauté
humanitaire de ce à la communauté
internationale de se réveiller sur ce
point de vue alors l'objectif des
nations unies cette journée un système
d'approvisionnement en eau et
d'assainissement pour toutes les
populations d'ici 2030
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
jouable selon vous comme je le disais
techniquement c'est jouable
par contre si on continue sur la
tendance actuelle on y arrivera
certainement pas on arrivera je peux
même vous le garantir pas il faut
aujourd'hui que le réveil se fasse que
les politiques d'eau de l'ensemble des
pays membres des nations unies soit
accompagnée de ressources de ressources
affectées mais pour ça encore une fois
il faut une volonté politique et la
problématique c'est que l'eau c'est le
problème de tout le monde mais ça semble
n'intéresser personne
l'eau n'est pas un sujet électoral sexy
contrairement à l'électricité
contrairement à la couverture
téléphonique
or sans eau il n'ya pas de développement
des grands centres urbains qui soient
pérennes il n'y a pas de développement
économique qui puisse tenir de tenir sur
la durée donc donc tout simplement il
faut remettre l'eau au coeur des enjeux
du développement économique et social
dans son débit merci beaucoup
thierry bayle la scène d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin je le rappelle
vous êtes directeur des opérations
solidarité internationale